[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi racconterò la storia di un'idea è
un'idea che si concretizza verso la fine
del secolo scorso e che prende piede in
maniera consistente e alla fine guadagna
quasi tutto lo spazio della fisica
teorica contemporanea si tratta
dell'idea che lo spazio e il tempo quali
noi abitualmente frequentiamo non siano
in realtà il confine la struttura ultima
della nostra realtà fisica ma possano
emergere da qualcosa di più profondo e
allora guardiamolo questo profondo
intanto che è lo spazio uno spazio
profondo che cosa ci suscita questo
spazio beh nessuno meglio di pass carlos
a dire del sì lance eternal distese spa
sensini ma frey il silenzio eterno di
questi spazi infiniti mi spaventa miss
commenta quindi a prescindere dalla
componente emotiva emozionale di pascal
pascal qui introduce due concetti
fondamentali lo spazio infinito e il
tempo eterno e non erano tempi così
facili per parlare di infiniti non
dimentichiamoci che pochi anni prima è
proprio sugli universi finiti giordano
bruno è finito arrosto chi raccoglie
comunque questa su questo suggerimento
di spazi infiniti e di di tempo eterno è
newton isacco newton che introduce nelle
sue equazioni
le fa diventare delle grandezze fisico
matematiche lo spazio del tempo e le
introduce nelle equazioni che spiegano
la gravitazione universale cioè come
l'universo sta in piedi e lo spazio di
newton è uno spazio assoluto è uno
spazio infinito lo spazio rigido e un
contenitore è un è un palcoscenico su
cui vanno in scena le leggi della natura
allo stesso modo il tempo è un tempo
scandito da un unico orologio che batte
la stessa ora in tutto lui questo è il
concetto di spazio di tempo in newton
chiedete a un fisico anche contemporaneo
che cosa sono lo spazio del tempo beh lo
spazio è quella cosa che
permette agli oggetti di stare separati
uno dall'altro e il tempo ecco la cosa
che permette agli eventi di una cadere
tutti insieme
vediamo se
questa definizione reggerà per tutta la
nostra chiacchierata
chi sconvolge questa idea di spazio
tempo newtoniana è newtoniano è
albert einstein all'inizio del secolo
scorso che con un'intuizione
spettacolare si chiede ma se io
inseguirsi un raggio di luce cosa
succederebbe beh non riuscirei mai ad
acchiapparlo ma non solo non riuscirei
ad acchiapparlo riscatterebbe sempre
davanti alla stessa velocità non
riuscirei mai ad accorciare le distanze
quindi da una valenza assoluta la
velocità della luce della velocità della
luce diventa una costante universale e
questo inevitabilmente siccome la
velocità e spazio diviso tempo dovrà
sacrificare l'assolutezza dello spazio
del tempo che diventano relativi questa
è l'idea di einstein spazio il tempo
vengono influenzati dalle moto di chi li
osserva e famoso l'esempio dei due
gemelli il gemello che sta sulla terra
quello che viaggia a delle velocità
molto alte su un'astronave perché gli
effetti relativistici si vedono solo a
velocità molto alta e viaggia a velocità
molto alta e nell'astronave quando torna
sulla terra scoprirà di essere più
giovane quindi il tempo è stato
influenzato dalle moto e quindi perde il
suo statuto ontologico di assoluto e
allo stesso modo anche lo spazio
la nuova struttura che einstein inventa
viene così bene raccontata da un suo
maestro che si chiamava harman in corsa
che nel 1908 in un famoso incontro dice
d'ora in poi lo spazio in sé il tempo in
sé sono destinati a ridursi a mera e
ombre è solo una sorta di unione dei due
conserverà una realtà indipendente con
questo sposalizio di spazio e tempo in
einstein diventa lo spazio tempo che
intabill mente sarà un oggetto
quadridimensionale tre dimensioni
spaziali le famose yz il tempo che
diventa a tutti gli effetti una
coordinata una dimensione dunque questo
tessuto spazio temporale è fatto di
trama e ordito e la trama è lo spazio e
l'ordito è il tempo
questo è un omaggio che ho voluto fare a
proust che nel 22 sono 100 anni
quest'anno sono 100 anni dalla sua morte
proust intuisce molto bene che cos'è
questo spazio tempo che non è
accessibile direttamente al nostro alla
nostra vista e neanche al nostro intuito
è difficilissimo intuire un oggetto
quadridimensionale però proust ci riesce
bene scrivendo nell'animare chef quando
descrive la cattedrale la chiesa di con
brett un edificio che occupava per così
dire uno spazio a quattro dimensioni la
quarta era quella del tempo e che
dispiegando attraverso i secoli la sua
navata sembrava aver varcato e sconfitto
di campata in campata di cappella in
cappella non solo qualche metro ma è m
ma qualche epoche successive dalle quali
usciva in trionfo ecco questa è la
restituzione proustiana del concetto
fisico matematico di spazio tempo allora
immaginiamo questa chiesa che ci
accompagnerà durante la nostra
conversazione come l'oggetto un oggetto
quadridimensionale è chiaro che dobbiamo
introdurre il tempo qua dentro non
possiamo pensare di vedere le quattro
dimensioni quindi usiamo le due spaziali
e una temporale se questo è il classe
del tempo lungo la navata della chiesa
allora se noi pensiamo di andare a
sezionare questo blocco spazio temporale
in un certo momento in un punto del
tempo quello che troviamo là dentro non
sarà una sezione ma sarà l'intera chiesa
congelata in un certo momento questo è
il concetto spazio temporale
einsteiniano che proposto intuisce molto
bene attenzione al 1913
evidentemente prus conosceva qualcosa
della relatività di einstein
e einstein prosegue nella sua idea di
universo
quadridimensionale e sviluppa anche lui
una teoria dieci anni dopo quindi almeno
100 quindi sulla teoria che spiega la
gravitazione universale
questa teoria si chiama la relatività
generale questa è l'equazione più
importante dell'attività generale che
sembra difficile in realtà se io traduco
questa equazione in italiano questa
equazione dice semplicemente la materia
e l'energia dicono lo spazio tempo come
curvarsi perché questo non sarà più uno
spazio tempo rigido come quello di
newton sarà uno spazio una gelatina
quindi modificabile quindi abbastanza
facilmente piegabile con la materia in
grado di spiegare i piegare lo spazio
tempo e lo spazio tempo insegnerà dirà
la materia come muoversi questo dice
l'equazione della relatività generale di
einstein quindi non esiste più la forza
di gravità
esiste una geometria che spiega la
gravitazione universale
l'altra grande teoria che si sviluppa in
questi anni e che spiega invece il coté
infinitamente piccolo della del nostro
universo la meccanica quantistica quindi
la relatività generale spiega
l'infinitamente grande e la meccanica
quantistica l'infinitamente piccolo
sono le due colonne portanti della
nostra fisica qui ho voluto diciamo
sintetizzare la meccanica quantistica
con un'equazione che una delle equazioni
più importanti di questa teoria
dall'equazione di harding è quello del
gatto il problema di queste due teorie
che funzionano benissimo quando vengono
prese singolarmente ma se tentiamo di
sposarle quindi di riunificare in uno
schema concettuale matematico
unico non ci riusciamo
sono anni che ci proviamo e non ci
riusciamo non non riescono a stare bene
insieme
questo è il vero collo di bottiglia
della nostra fisica contemporanea
superato questo collo di bottiglia
capiremo veramente la struttura ultima
dello spazio tempo quella che si chiama
la gravità quantistica
la struttura ultima lo spazio tempo
nelle sue componenti infinitamente
estese e infinitamente piccole e il
laboratorio ideale per studiare questi
problemi è il buco nero questa è
un'immagine molto bella di buco nero che
è stata restituita dalla organizzazione
dalla rete ht un mese fa ed è la
fotografia del buco nero che sta al
centro nostra galassia molto vicino a
noi a 27 mila anni luce questo è il
laboratorio ideale per studiare insieme
la gravità quantistica e scusate la
gravità di vita generale e la meccanica
quantistica cioè l'eventualità di una
gravità quantistica
e qui veniamo al problema
a questa idea questa idea un po
sovversiva dello spazio tempo
e questa idea nasce proprio dallo studio
negli ultimi anni del secolo scorso
della della gara fisica dei buchi neri e
da letto e dalla fisica dei buchi neri
che stiamo capendo queste cose allora
banalmente se voi pensate di riempire
una scatola con degli oggetti la domanda
è in quanti modi io posso riempire
questa scatola pensate al al baule di di
una macchina in quanti modi posso
disporre le valigie beh dipende dal
volume più al volume a disposizione più
riesco a infilare roba e co modalità
diverse ecco scoperta importante è che
studiando i buchi neri quindi materia
estremamente compatta estremamente densa
si è capito che non è così che le
modalità il numero di modalità di
arrangiare degli oggetti dentro una
scatola non dipende dal volume ma
dipende dalla superficie che sembra
strano ma è così il concetto è che io
posso descrivere il contenuto di uno
spazio tridimensionale
utilizzando uno spazio a una dimensione
in meno c'è uno spazio bidimensionale
cioè la superficie le pareti che
avvolgono quel volume
è chiaro che in uno spazio
tridimensionale ci stanno molte più cose
che in uno spazio bidimensionale e
quindi questo scarto dimensionale
farebbe pensare a una ridondanza
dimensionale del volume quindi di uno
spazio che comincia a scricchiolare
vediamo come
questa idea poi viene concretizzata con
un nome il principio olografico perché
perché già nella fine degli anni del
secolo scorso si sapeva che esisteva
l'olografia che cos'è un ologramma un
ologramma una lamina dimensionale
bidimensionale la mina in due dimensioni
su cui vengono depositate delle
informazioni e quando queste
informazioni sono sufficientemente bene
illuminate creano un'immagine
tridimensionale che ha un'immagine
immateriale però è a tutti gli effetti
un oggetto tridimensionale
questo oggetto voi potete girare intorno
occupa effettivamente un volume non è
solo un'immagine bidimensionale
ecco perché è stato questa idea è stata
battezzata al principio lo grafico ora
cercherò di spiegare un po meglio di che
cosa si tratta e lo farò banalizzando un
po necessariamente cercando di
esemplificare questo con un
piccolo esempio è
l'idea è di entrare per un momento nella
di nuovo in questa cattedrale in questo
spaziotempo quadridimensionale
e
dimentichiamo per un momento il tempo
congeliamo in un certo momento e
introduciamo in questo spazio
un aquilotto
questo aquilotto
necessariamente avrà la sua ombra
attenzione l'ombra si proietta sulla
parete e l'ombra è per antonomasia per
definizione l'oggetto l'unico oggetto
che a me risulta squisitamente
autenticamente bidimensionale che
abbiamo al mondo l'ombra è l'unico
oggetto che non ha spessore
e quindi è bene
utilizzato in questo caso un oggetto
squisitamente bidimensionale adesso
facciamo un piccolo salto concettuale
facciamo finta che questo aquilotto sia
invisibile quindi il contrario di un
vampiro
vediamo solo la sua ombra lui non lo
vediamo allora la domanda che vi faccio
ed alla
studio di all'ombra che lascia questa
aquilotto siamo in grado di ricostruire
i movimenti dell'aquilotto dentro alla
chiesa che vuol dire l'aquilotto ha a
disposizione uno spazio tridimensionale
l'ombra a uno spazio a disposizione
dimensionale cioè la parete della chiesa
siamo in grado di ricostruire tutti i
movimenti di un aquilotto in uno spazio
tridimensionale solo con quella sua
ombra sì perché chiaramente se mi devo
girare
l'aquila 8 si muove in questa direzione
lo vediamo se si muove in questa
direzione
lo vediamo perché l'ombra si sposta il
problema è quando si muove in questa
direzione
la terza dimensione
e qui non è che può staccarsi l'ombra da
terra dal staccarsi l'ombra dalla
superficie e
è però attenzione se
l'aquilotto si avvicina al muro
aquilotto invisibile si avvicina nulla
quest'ombra diventerà più piccola se
invece l'aquilotto si avvicina alla
finestra di là questa onda diventerà più
grande e quindi dallo studio della forma
dell'ombra io sono in grado di
ricostruire completamente il movimento
dell'aquilotto dentro al volume e quindi
di nuovo
evidentemente cc salta all'occhio questa
in qualche modo ridondanza dello spazio
siamo in grado di dire le stesse cose
usando solo le superfici il poeta la
direbbe così karol orazio ci stanno più
cose nel mio volume di quante ne possa
immaginare la tua superficie e il fisico
risponde cauley elmo con la mia sola
superficie io riesco a raccontare tutto
ciò che accade il tuo volume
e e quindi scricchiola davvero il
concetto di spazio
perché
possiamo giocare con degli scarti
dimensionali e quindi la conclusione
l'idea ci porta a questa conclusione
lo spazio tempo è superfluo e questo ci
induce a pensare che ci potrebbe essere
una struttura sottostante più
elementare da cui lo spazio tempo emerge
questa è un'ipotesi è un'ipotesi fondata
proprio su questi studi qualcosa
impedisce a quello spazio tempo di
adempiere totalmente alla funzione di
separatore di eventi quali lo avevamo
definito all'inizio di questa
conversazione
è la sostanza è questa esistono
evidentemente dello spazio nello spazio
tempo delle correlazioni che non
conosciamo le correlazioni nascoste le
famose correlazioni quantistiche che
rendono gli eventi nello spazio tempo
tra di loro non più separabili e quindi
in qualche modo non più indipendenti
quindi questo spazio non è più un
oggetto una cosa in grado di separare
tenere separati gli oggetti no gli
oggetti hanno evidentemente delle
relazioni tra loro che ancora non
conosciamo e questa è materia di studio
della fisica contemporanea e torniamo
alla caverna di platone
ritorniamo alla caverna di platone dove
c'è il
prigioniero che può vedere solo
un'immagine bidimensionale e pensa che
quella sia la realtà vera del dl del
mondo è in realtà la realtà vera sta
dietro di lui è una realtà
tridimensionale
qui di concetto rimane valido la visione
del mondo è soltanto una proiezione di
come il mondo è realmente questo è vero
però è ribaltata la realtà vera non è
quella che noi osserviamo
tridimensionale ma è quella che sta là
dietro
depositata su una qualche superficie
cioè un ombra e di nuovo il poeta
direbbe siamo ombra di ombra
bene
le conclusioni che possiamo trarre che
possiamo dedurre da questa idea sono
piuttosto forti
intanto probabilmente lo spazio tempo
non è così fondamentale
oltre il confine dello spazio tempo c'è
qualcos'altro c'è una struttura
probabilmente più profonda le deduzioni
pratiche che possiamo trarre sono beh
allora noi potremmo essere degli
ologrammi
degli ologrammi di una informazione che
vive da qualche parte sulla
sull'orizzonte esterno del nostro
universo sulla superficie esterna
dell'universo visibile depositata ii e
noi siamo degli ologrammi
oppure noi potremmo essere addirittura
delle una simulazione di un programma
caricato su un supercomputer ma chi l'ha
fatto quel programma beh potrebbe averlo
fatto un altro programma ancora più
potente e andiamo avanti con una
regressione all'infinito e chiaro che
qui il terreno si fa davvero scivoloso e
quindi è un buon momento per
non andare avanti e chiuderla con woody
allen secondi cosa fosse un illusione
non resistesse beh in questo caso io ho
pagato molto caro il mio tappeto troppo
caro
[Musica]
mutu